that should have been over and and back
mcgee hit that
here's anthony davis he'll pull a
mid-range and knocks it down
fires on his first three attempt james
pushes gives it up all the way across
the floor
kentavious called well pope hits at
three and if the lakers do that
it's over lebron with a long three
and that one's down lebron james i just
want to say to the mom but thank you
for what you did for the nba great to
see the
kids from the mambo league as danny
green
hits another three what a start for the
lakers here
bullet pass to davis steps inside the
three-point arc it knocks down another
long two that's the second time
signature move except to get buckets and
right here on the turnaround
tough shot great follow through great
hand in the face just
better oh nurkic with the put back
see how the paint just opened up there
for lillard but
at the same time now this is what you
get on the other nurkic
with the put back see how the paint just
opened up there for
lillard but at the same time now this is
what you get on the other end
mccullum gives it up oh mellow took some
contact he wants a foul
none called and it's a breakaway for the
lakers and
los angeles just making it look easy
right now figure this is go time for
portland now laker bench on the floor
his contavious caldwell pope he's
touched
so kcp will head to the line
over kuzma in here kcp just attacking
a.d from the mid-range kcp
nice he ca he was the difference
and look at that score huh on mama day
24 to 8.